hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I am just checking in on you
who's that checking in on you you can't
sorry I'm in New York you know all of a
sudden you're just going to start doing
your little Sinatra vibe dude I'm going
out now buying a new pair of [__]
sneakers today do where you going to get
you you're gonna get to Jordan five do I
know what I'm going to get you know I'm
going to I'm getting some old man
running sneakers I need some workout
sneakers you know how about the ones
that were on better call Saul for the
old ladies do you guys watch the rest of
that series did you see it yet can I
ruin it for you I got to tell you in the
last episode in the last scene when the
guy says just trying to get all you guys
to scamper for your [__] pause
buttons no no no I think what you said
people literally run out of the room
people run out of the [__] room when
you start talking about a show they
haven't seen the last episode you know
they do that you don't to me but if you
just sit there and you [__] somebody
rips a fart people just put a [__]
shirt over their nose huh who did that
you're literally inhaling air from this
guy's ass you know that doesn't make you
leave the room but if so god forbid
somebody brings up the last episode of a
[__] show you haven't seen everybody
runs out like the buildings on fire it
is a perfect perfect day in New York
City the breeze dude this breeze top
five breezes ever this breeze my top
five ever that's a birdie thing first he
would actually rank his breezes top five
breezes ever dude I was sitting there
and on a pair of Jordan sixes with the
[__] v-neck with the chain on the
outside over-over waitress came up to me
she could barely take my order she
couldn't she couldn't even like she was
taken in the whole thing it was
ridiculous
new pair of guest jeans over [__]
anyways yeah so I'm up in [__]
porchetta
and then what Porchester is I know
Westchester there's East Chester and
Alva Deli there's Port Chester which I
believe is just Connecticut I'm there
tonight on there Tamara and then I'm
there on yeah and then I'm done and I'm
back and I'll say right now you have not
experienced loneliness so you have a
[__] kid and let and then you leave
my favorite part of the [__] days
when my kid wakes up you don't I mean
because like there's super [__]
rested and they just you know life
hasn't beaten them down yet they don't
have any credit card debt then I've got
some psycho blowing up their phone they
don't have this [__] they got to do some
[__] receipt they have to find they
got a they has nothing the look of
contentment on her face you know when
you go down when you go to give her a
kiss like she lifts all of her limbs
come up like a baby's ability to do leg
lifts I don't know how the [__] if I try
to do what she did just straight up as
you lifts them right up I don't get it
except it's sucking their toes evidently
I was that flexible at one point tell
you that a couple million miles in the
back of the [__] plane that'll that
will take the infant right out of you
it'll take the Apple right out of your
eyes that's what I miss the most so that
I always FaceTime with my lovely lady
and that's the best it's the best but it
sucks when I'm on the road but I just
out here being like you know what I'm
earning money some day so when she has
to go to private [__] kindergarten
for 90 grand a year or whatever the hell
it cost because evidently she goes to a
public school she's going to get stabbed
you know
what happened what happened to the
public schools was it the computers is
that what it was everybody had to have a
tablet a laptop some sort of interface
then what happened and went right
through the funding and all of a sudden
we couldn't keep up with China how to
[__] his china beatnik the overhead of a
[__] billion people alone I mean we
should be like we should get everything
at a 60% discount over here as far as
educating our own people does it make
any sense does any of it make any
[__] sense does it make any sense how
so many people are [__] struggling
out there and they just keep building
the luxury apartments and these [__]
giant goddamn houses who are you
right and they only adds money from
Russia it's running from China
it's oil money from the Middle East now
listen I don't know what to do about
China I don't know what to do about
Russia and I don't know what to do about
the Middle East but that's not going to
stop me from telling you what to do
about all these things I just ate why is
my stomach grumbling this is all you got
to do for the Middle East okay oh we go
things we just your [__] you embrace
solar power that's it how do we do that
how do we do that with the oil companies
if somebody [__] it would be if we
actually win the solar direction when a
bunch of planes start crashing that had
the leaders of the solar movement on
them yes that would definitely happen
they would definitely take them up so
what do you do this is what you do you
give the Sun to the oil people okay you
drop a contract and you say the Sun is
yours all right now what are they going
to do with the Sun they can't put it out
they can't touch it it will burn their
[__] hands but they just make the
money off the [__] the solar power
okay and they could just somehow handle
that those people in the Middle East are
sitting on a bunch of goop that they can
make money off of they could just
seamlessly [__] walk away from that
[__] if I was president I would
literally give all companies federal
[__] grants to [__] get the solar
thing going you guys own the Sun I would
just keep walking but your own
and they be said before bonobos is
stuffing this stuff with a middle waist
over dude [__] that stuff all right
your that stuff is that that stuff's
like God of sub-second Atari like the
Reebok pumps nobody gives a [__] okay
this is the new [__] this is the new
[__] we're giving you the [__] son
son understand that you own the center
of this solar system alright and every
[__] little bit of heat that comes
off that thing that trickles down on a
Mike freckled ball goddamn head you own
you put a [__] meter right on my back
I don't give a [__] okay and I know what
you guys are thinking built this doesn't
make any [__] sense I don't get it
let's listen me hear me up it give these
people to stun you give them the goddamn
Sun alright and then what what happens
over in the Middle East that's sitting
on all of this [__] group all right
and all of a sudden it's not worth it's
not worth diddly squat okay and all of a
sudden the [__] the bills start
piling up they don't know what to do
they start selling their properties over
here they want to give money to the
terrorist groups they don't got the
money to do it yep
[__] bleed them dry then that's it
and then they go back to doing whatever
the [__] they want to do over there god
forbid they live their lives the way
they want to live it over there god
forbid they're not into Jesus in
Starbucks God for [__] bit they want
to walk around and some clothes that are
actually functional for the part of the
world they live in you just leave them
the [__] alone and then all they got to
do is just keep driving around in cars
and all of that [__] so they you know
they'll make a lot less money but they
won't have us over there go now you
should do this
you should do that we just get the [__]
out of there then we're over here
solar-powered everything right just
think about everything think about your
shirt solar-powered everything
everything [__] solar-powered I know
what you're thinking well build what
happens at night you go to bed what do
people do in Alaska during the winter
[__] them
we got to get out we gotta get out of
that place if it's the last thing we
ever do it's bankrupting us it's making
very few people a ton of [__] money
it is bankrupting us we're not going to
you cannot solve that [__] ok so now
that we know you can't solve it because
I said you can't solve it without doing
any research now that would now that
I've established that as a fact on my
own podcast
the only thing other reason to be over
there is there sitting on all that goop
but now we don't need the group the
group the group the group is on fire we
don't give a [__] keep it right you give
the Sun to the oil companies that's it
just go total solar power you know Jimmy
Carter that Georgia peanut farmer he
said it four years ago said we are
addicted to oil we've had we just kept
going and going and going and now look
at us now look at us now look at a
spending all this [__] money over
there they give it to the [__] that a
shooting [__] at us right and then we
shooting back at them they're making all
this money and then they come over here
they buy a 50 [__] thousand square
foot house overlooking our [__]
overlooking our chick okay we overlook
you we're up on the hill not the other
way around huh
you give them the Sun oh god you guys
I'm telling you I would have that I
would [__] sell was oil guys I would
have a meeting under a mountain whoever
the [__] meet with these [__]
people that really run [__] you know you
underneath the mountain you got this -
[__] underwater waterfalls and [__]
right these like these planted the eight
[__] things walking or whatever the
[__] goes on underneath that thing right
and you just tell that [__] so I can't
into a water folder my [__] the dude
from police academy I can't do that
sound effects gentlemen I came here I
came underneath this mountain tonight to
give you the Sun I'm sorry I don't have
my proper recording equipment here I
can't I can't do my Illuminati meeting
you give him the [__] the [__] Sun
take out of the Sun give them the
[__] Sun buh-buh-buh-buh-buh that's
what I would do instead of going over
there talking about evil doers and doers
of evil and [__] this that and the
other you packed the whole [__] [__]
up that's it pack it all up spent over
10 cargo planes you bring the men and
women of the ABS force this you bring
them home right you say you can keep
your goop you can keep you sad but I
want some of those cool clothes I like
the clothes they wear over there the
giant open-ended 1p whatever the [__]
you call it I think those things are
cool man I wish I want one of those can
i buy one of those without offending
Muslims could I talk my way out of a
beheading if I put one of those on just
Rick look man I'm a redhead it was hot
out I am what am I supposed to do
then they get my face you'll blow it
that's it that's all I wanted to say
today give the oil companies the Sun you
give it to them and then the whole
[__] thing is over whatever I believe
I can fly so I get a gig here tonight
and I'm going to go I'm gonna go play
some drums is a little rehearsal studio
down the street I'm going to go play my
[__] drums for a couple hours I was
going to go ride around on one of those
[__] Citibank [__] banker [__]
bicycles but there's never any they got
like 14 for the whole city and then also
what kind of an [__] rides a bicycle
in a city you don't I mean what am I in
Europe how many people die a year in
Europe just riding around on bicycles in
a [__] city those [__] cars go by
Kwami blah blah blah me [__] yet
another ambulance going over to pick up
some [__] six foot three inch [__]
110 pound European that you could take
it out on a bicycle it has a basket on
the front I like riding bicycles oh you
know what I watched this documentary
called ovarian psychos right how do you
not click on that I first clicked on
this action movie and it was just the
same [__] [__] the one guy beats the
[__] out of everybody
nobody ever they all have guns but they
never think to use it and I was just
like I've seen this a million times it's
really loud and look at that nice
classic car they're wrecking the [__]
thing I I can't watch the [__] so I shut
it off and I saw this thing called
ovarian psychos and I was like I want to
I got it like I see what this is about
it was about some so women in East LA
mainly Mexican who were sick of [__]
being scared women and they started
their own group when they ride around
these women's only you know riding
bicycles when there's like a full moon
or some [__] I don't know I don't know
so I was watching this stuff and of
course typical guys look who women told
me cuz like substance
what about God only buzz right I hate
when people act like it's a level
playing field you know what I mean it's
like they're having this thing because
it's not a level playing field one of
the women and there was looks like
everything's kind of for [__] men
only which it really is when you really
look at it okay I don't want to [__]
come off of a complete goddamn liberal
here all right but you know it really is
it's it's just it's there for the takin
for you when you're a guy you know not
saying you're going to get it 9 out of
10 people still fail that's one thing
that feminists don't realize you know
you listen to them talking about what
it's like to be a guy who had this
cartoonish idea of what it's like to be
a guy you just show up oh and then the
classic one the more you act like a dick
the more people respect you I love that
one if a woman of a woman does it she's
considered a [__] if a guy does it it's
like have they ever done a servant just
ask the general public hey if you have
your choice between working for somebody
nice or working for a complete [__]
[__] who treats you like [__] which
would you pick yeah nobody does I think
when I need successful people truly
successful people that get it successful
in their personal life and in their
professional life those people I always
lead they're always humble they're
self-deprecating they walk into a room
you want to be around them and they're
good at talking to people they don't
come in like [__] Alec Baldwin and
Glengarry Glen Ross that [__] that
men respect a guy like that [__] who
the [__] wouldn't know I don't I don't
respect anybody like what I see is an
insecure [__] who's afraid it's all
going to go away by the afternoon anyway
stop watching this documentary check it
out it's actually really the only get
bothered me about the documentary is the
way they spelled psychos ovarian psychos
it's like the you're on cycles so why
don't you spell the first half like
cycle and the rest like psycho you know
little wordplay too
nothing all right anyways so I watched
it it was interesting and I shoot this
one woman said in it you know because
she'd been through all this [__] when
she was a little girl with their mother
and then she had a daughter I believe
she at least she had a kid she became a
mom and then her mother said well now do
you at least understand me I bet you
understand me a lot more and she said to
her mother no actually I've never
understood you less and I actually
cringed when I when I saw that I was
just like you know that's something if
you feel it you don't say to your mom
like what do you get out of saying that
to your mother all you're going to do is
devastate her and make her feel like she
completely failed as a mom and it
doesn't get you any real estate that's
something you say to your friend and now
that I have a kid is just like I don't
even understand what the [__] my mother
did to me even more heaven and you
[__] clink your wine coolers and then
that's it you don't say it to your mom
we're taking kalus I just watched a
Schick Hydro transformer ad that made
those Dollar Shave Club ads make even
more [__] sense the blade literally
turned into one of those [__] robots
why is Mutombo Wagon is finger at me
like he just blocked a shot in a mobile
one commercial is he out of NBA money
where the [__] did he come from out of
nowhere did he buy one too many [__]
gold chains or some [__] and either like
called up his agent I need to work again
that Schwarzenegger I don't know I don't
know idea I don't have my ads I'll have
to read the ad at the end of this
[__] thing whenever whenever the [__]
that thing comes in I have no idea oh by
the way I forgot to bring this up season
3 of f is for family is going to happen
thank you so much to everybody who
watched we are now breaking stories for
season 3 it's animation so season 3
ought to come out somewhere in late 2019
now we're hoping that we can have a come
out you know we came out May 30th of
this year so we're that's when I'm
personally that's what I'm shooting for
now I haven't communicated that to
anybody at work I'm working with I'm
just assuming that they already know
that and if it doesn't happen I will
just get quiet for no reason around them
that's the way I was taught to
communicate with others while growing up
do all the math in your head do not
communicate it to anybody and when they
don't see it the way you see it you just
stop talking to people that was the way
it was done and then you just don't talk
to them for like three days and then
then when they finally like well I guess
I'm not going to [__] talk to you
again you then out of nowhere bring up
whatever game happened last night and
you start talking about it like the last
three days never [__] happened that's
the way it was done when I was growing
up today one of these days I'm actually
going to fly up to Port Chester and
helicopter I'm trying to convince this
guy to put dual controls on it's the
whole [__] purpose of me going right
fly over the George Washington Bridge I
just want to see how you transition
through all this [__] commercial
airspace where you have JFK you have
LaGuardia and you have Newark but I see
helicopters all the time going up and
down the Hudson Bay so there's got to be
some corridor that they're allowed to
slide like probably I would guess no
higher than like I don't know they fly
really [__] low but I never know if
it's like sightseeing I wouldn't think
you'd be any higher than a thousand feet
and you just kind of you know and then
just look out for Sully when he comes to
landed another big I do know with LAX
that you need to transition along the
beach at a below 150 or you go along
Sepulveda Boulevard which I never do
that one that one always scares the [__]
out of me
because you look down and there's a
jumbo jet underneath you and I always
think like what a few BOTS is landing
and just [__]
Yanks back on the stick then I got this
[__] 300 person missile coming right
at me in my little r22 you know you ever
see a cheetah running down a baby
whatever that's what it would be like
except it's the aviation version of that
and I would be the baby gazelle that's
not even a gazelle a baby turtle how
slow is a baby turtle is there anything
sadder than watching that documentary
when those baby turtles try to make it
to the ocean and all those [__]
seagulls come down and pick off nine out
of ten of them
I [__] love turtles I had a pet
turtle when I was a kid and he's
defeated like dead grasshoppers and [__]
I love this [__] thing I love
cleaning the tank making sure its shell
stayed [__] wet know that so it
wouldn't crack and I had my little tank
set it up I [__] love this thing I
love watching it coming up for air and
all that [__] so one time I went to
church because that's what I used to do
every Sunday right so I went to church
with my family baggies so we go to
church and I came home and the turtle
was red positioned the rock the turtle
had gone head first into the water and
it's turtle ass was out of the water and
I mean it went over and I picked it up
and its head was sunk all the way back
into it's like shell and its eyes were
closed and his mouth was open and it
wasn't moving and I was like oh [__]
it's a dead did it drown and I went
downstairs and I said dad it's my turtle
dead a guy's gone
and I was [__] devastated so I took a
ready to take a brown you know you put
your lunch in the brown like lunch bags
put the turtle in there and then I went
out the woods dug it a little grave and
put the marker up and then that was it
and then my dad was like we'll get you
another one we'll get you another one I
was like no I don't deserve it I blamed
Turtles it was my fault they set up the
[__] The Rock's wrong and that was
just such a goes I that's it that's it
I'm done you know I'm done I'm not going
to kill another [__] turtle and it
was so weird like four days later we
were driving down the street and it was
a turtle crossing the street this is
back when there was actually animals you
know before we [__] killed and ate
all of them you know I blame the Food
Network for that you know at least
[__] asshole's going around eating
bizarre foods
I'm in Timbuktu we maggot right now the
sudden everybody got to eat maggots are
serving grasshoppers
it [__] Mariner games or whatever the
hell they're doing up there
this is America we don't eat
grasshoppers
we ate the radios Taco Bell you give
them the Sun everybody I'm telling you
that would turn this country around turn
this country around
just get in the Sun that's it so anyways
I flew the other day on on Tuesday
hadn't flown like a month and I flew
like a [__] champ to the point I
actually got a goddamn compliment from
my instructor unsolicited said you're
flying great today made me feel really
good ok I've done my auto rotations I'm
ready to get back out there and solo so
there's a flight I want to do I want to
fly up to stand a [__] Barbara solo
so that's what I'm working towards and
I'm really looking forward to it
been flying a lot in the valley and
everything getting to know all of that
stuff
it's so [__] cool yesterday we were
actually two days of going and try to
fly over to Santa Monica Airport
because I know that they're going to
they're allegedly closing it in five
years we'll see what the [__] happens
cells I go I never landed there I might
as well go over and check that place out
but what we wanted to do like pad work
they don't like to do that over there
noise abatement stand all that gonna
want some helicopter flying around on a
large ship so we just said [__] it we
flew up along the coast went by the
Pacific Palisades you just sitting there
looking that's what this up the whole
given the Sun [__] came from I looked I
said look at that [__] house they're
building this house was the size of this
house I looked at it and I said to the
instructor go that looks like a building
a [__] mall that I would never go
into going like that's going to be too
crowded and it was somebody's house it
was going to cost half a [__] billion
dollars and there was some prints of
some [__] country in the Middle East
you know was going to move that's like
his [__] house on the other side of
the world
that's his cottage and that right there
I was just like how much [__] money
we given to these people it's time to
give you all companies to some that's
that's all you do so they're still in
control of everything you know they
could give us empty threats well shut it
off you know like they can do it
so anyways were flying over there and
I'm just looking at all these [__]
houses and I look down I see this one it
was [__] beautiful house I go Jesus
Christ look at that one it having this
glass where you couldn't see in at all
like sealing the floors is [__] look
like a goddamn yacht but it was a house
and those guys they always give tours so
they know all the celebrities I got it
so it's those [__] house sounds like
wow that's what twenty million a movie
gives you and I'm not going to say the
guy's name because he probably has
enough [__] people looking at his
house although recently they said that
he sold it so I have no [__] idea but
anyways I had a great time I did have a
great time the only thing is whenever I
land off airport I all the [__] [__]
that I know to do the downwind checks
you know all of that I forget to do all
of it that's the only part I [__] up
so we're doing like this pinnacle
landing and I
you know you set up downwind base and
then go final and I [__] you know I
was coming in for a landing I was still
doing like sixty five not six I'm
supposed to be down to like thirty you
know slow and downs and shitty guys
going are you going a little fast
I want to do some s turns here but
anyways I am uh yeah very excited to do
that type of [__] and this is the time
when I would usually read some advertise
in there but I don't have any what else
can I talk about here look it up
hmm I have to hum my password or else I
can't you know I got in here late and I
watched a little bend of the [__]
Yankees game the baby bombers over there
so I can kick in the [__] out of
everybody oh you know I love about my
building here in New York is we have
rooftop access in timber for me I feel
like that's part of the New York spirits
you got to be up on a [__] roof the
only thing that sucks is you can't smoke
up there you know they just have like
chairs I don't think you can smoke I
just said smoke anything you can eat you
know what I mean I think you just can go
up there and like read books it's like
what the [__] you know I mean it's
probably cameras up bacon and go up
there and bang your broad I don't like
this guy like huh you're like [__]
scaling and he can't do that anymore
back in the day back in the 90s when I
was there I got pawnshop on in the
background somebody's trying to sell a
Murray Eliminator you look so those are
going to Paolo three-speed I think I
don't know if you guys noticed but bill
on ethics her family has a bike like
that that was a bike I always wanted and
my parents are like no we're going to
get you the nerdy more [__] when I
can get you one of those cool chopper
looking bikes we're going to get you one
of the [__] nerdy ones you know Beach
Rambler let's see what the [__] this
guy's asking for this the f3 eliminator
9 I mean eliminate our mark - what are
you going to do how much you going to
get through this is really always [__]
them over
actually the see some of the metal Fleck
as you can see has a little scratch on
it
so I'm going to give you one ninetieth
of what your asking price was you know
kills me those [__] bikes were like I
don't know what they're gonna like 60 70
bucks which is a lot of money back in
the day and now they're worth like
hundreds and hundreds of dollars called
inflation it's called the Federal
Reserve all right I just went down the
rabbit hole
alright um that is because I was just
checking in on you guys I just give you
a couple of laughs on your ride home or
whatever the [__] it is that you're
doing I guess I'll do the advertising
read whenever the [__] I get that I'll
just splice it on the end of this which
is what you're gonna listen to in two
seconds so I don't know why I just
explained it all right
by the way balcony seats for Paul virzi
stand-up special on August 13 at the
Tarrytown Music Hall have now gone on
sale tickets are going fast for the two
shows I'm very excited about me and uh
Pete Davidson are going to go out go out
before Paul's show to warm up the crowd
that night do a little [__] Smothers
Brothers thing I think we're just going
to try out new material I'm going to run
that by him we just you know he'll try a
new joke and I'll try a new joke and
then you guys get the judge it who's you
like better all right and then whoever
[__] wins gets a goddamn pie I don't
know what we'll figure something I was
going to be a great night so thank you
everybody but watching this mr. family
and thank you for helping out the all
things comedy network reproducing our
first stand-up special with the great
Paul virzi who soon to become a
household name soon to start selling out
nationwide developing a drug habit leave
family taking his family back east is
taking the [__] Hollywood ride not
Posner could do that I can't wait to see
Paul virzi with money I cannot [__]
wait first of all his bedrooms going to
look like a footlocker he's going to
have all his [__] Jordans up on the
wall he's going to have like 19
different he's going to have a gold
chain for every [__] day of the month
kind of car would he likes for to us
again some giant gangster [__]
looking car you know a [__] walk-in
humidor I can't wait to see it I really
can't wait to see it it's going to be
there's certain people you know they get
money that [__] boring I've been
guilty of that but there's other people
you like god I can't wait to see this
this is going to be some [__]
legendary [__] I feel like if I came
into Paul's house and he somehow in a
split entry house figured out how to put
a word the world is mine fountain at the
foot of the landing of the [__] two
stairs one goes up one goes down I
wouldn't surprise me in the least and I
can't wait to see it because I love the
guy alright that's it here comes some
advertising that I'm going to read some
point in the future but you're going to
hear it now
have a great weekend you [__] tents
over there and thank you to everybody
but tickets out here in Port Chester
I'll see you tonight tomorrow
say cheese alright black cops everybody
there's only so many opportunities in
life to wear a tuxedo yeah when you're
under a mop giving people the Sun give
you the Sun so when your big day or
special event rolls around this spring
look just as great as you feel man for
me they feel better when a really black
tux at last tux calm with high quality
rental suits and tuxedos delivered to
your doorstep be laptops gives you a new
way to rent what with their free home
try on you get to see the fit and feel
the quality of suit let your balls roll
around the past month before the event
before your event and the best part is
it's completely done online with laptops
comm lets you create your look or choose
from
style fantastic selected outfits I love
you do this on the internet someday when
your [__] robot replacement shows up
dressed like James Bond like everything
I set up I reckon I did thanks let it
[__] kill you at least it'll be a
gentleman robot just like this usually
retail for twelve hundred bucks doing
but as the black tux they start at just
ninety five dollars why would you say
twelve hundred bucks yeah they just
start at 95 up at $1,200 one no Jesus if
you have any questions at issue they're
the expert customer can eat says your
back every step of the way after
ordering your stool arrived 14 days
before your event if anything is less
than perfect but the black tux will send
you a free replacement right away when
your event is over just drop your
wrinkled back in the mail shipping is
free both ways how easy is that stand
out at your event for the right reasons
with black cups to get $20 off your
purchase with envy black tux calm slash
work that the black tux complex work for
$20 off of your purchase all right lift
everybody lifts notes with their drivers
or what keep them moving so they do
everything they can to make sure that
drivers are happy on every trip and lift
is the ride-sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
lift this is so much shade against uber
it's hilarious we actually treat our
people like people with believes that
being a ride-sharing drivers should be
fun and you're having a good time
driving a good time so are your
passengers welcome II was in reason
lipless can think of some scenarios well
it was possible a wimp was the first to
offer in a pity when you drive for lyft
you keep a hundred percent of the test
drivers have been pay over 200 million
dollars in tips since to be sure was
introduced Express paid lets drivers get
paid almost instantly instead of waiting
for weeks lyft has even taken the
guesswork out of pickups the new amp
device uses color coding to help add
your spine their drivers you can earn
hundreds
actually really cool I always wonder why
they will lit up differently you can
earn hundreds of dollars a week quest
kiss want to earn more money bribe or
it's never been easier to give you
supple rate it's a simple formula at the
driver's mean happy passengers
maybe that's why 9 out of 10 the price
at a perfect 5 star rating go to lists
comm / birth today and you can get a
$500 new driver bonus that's with ly
ft.com / for lyft comp / / limited time
only terms apply all right that ends the
ex-miss sneak please enjoy the music and
a half hour of a special Thursday
afternoon podcast from Thursday
afternoon that went by or maybe never
happens
[Music]
[Applause]
keep us together
[Music]
but
dumbu one day
[Music]
shut the [__] up
and
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
this is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday June 29th 2009 and that was an
mp3 by one of my listeners kind of an
old-school one which I kind of liked you
know little old-school a little
new-school you know still had had the
80s heavy metal radio station sound to
it and then it also had like that
the newer sort of what do they call that
Cookie Monster singing where people like
you know I really respect the
musicianship of being able to play that
fast but I have to admit I maybe I'm too
old but I just can't listen to some guy
go without laughing or it just seems
ridiculous to me but but maybe that's me
I don't know but uh thank you for the I
know those things take a long time to
put together so I appreciate anybody who
does one and I actually got I got
another one this week or so next week
there'll be a different intro and if you
new to my podcast that's one of the
thing every once in a while one of my
listeners will put together an mp3 and
then it takes me eight days to figure
out how to [__] sync it up in
GarageBand I just wish I knew a way
where I got I could play it and talk
over it like you would on like a [__]
uh I guess a radio show if anybody knows
how to do that you know what there was a
[__] question I was going to ask you
guys some sort of computer question
goddamnit I got I got to write these
things down I really got to write these
things down anyways I'm still in New
York City everybody I am down to my the
final week I just have one more scene to
shoot I got two lines that's all I got
left and then I then I'm out of the
movie and it's been it's been great it's
been a great experience and but I am
going a little bit nuts because I've
been away from my life for so long
which I don't know I think a lot of you
guys maybe don't get to experience
change that if you have more of a real
life where you get to just go to work
and then come home you know like when
you go on vacation how it's fun for the
first [__] week
you know and everything's cool maybe
takes a couple days to relax but then
there comes to that point where you get
into vacation where you're kind of ready
to go home and you know you need to you
need to you just need to sleep in your
own bed yeah I just want to go home you
know see my dog and [__] you know put
them in a full put you know put on a
full nelson maybe give her a couple of
jabs to her little doggy nose that's
another thing if you're new to my
podcast I really love kicking the [__]
out of my dog it's of kidding you know
now you know what this really is this is
me my inability to say that I miss
people in my life okay this is my my
[__] Irish Boston you know inability
to hug right now to say that I actually
you know maybe miss some people in my
life see I have to have an ambiguous
right now so anyways yeah so I've been
[__] staying here in New York you
know going to the same goddamn diner
every morning and I know this is a
really hacky premise and I say that
every week as I throw out hacky [__] but
what is the deal with ordering orange
orange juice and they charge HR I had a
small they charge me 450 you know I got
a couple of eggs so I thought I was
going to come in and about like [__]
you know the $13 range and next thing
you know it's like I owe like 25 bucks
is because I ordered a [__] orange
juice is it cuz everybody loves it you
know there's no shortage of oranges it's
I don't know Jesus Christ this podcast
sock this ruthless podcast really sucks
thank God I had an intro cuz right I did
I literally just ran out of steam right
there you know what is the deal with
oranges Ville huh alright let's talk
about some [__] topical [__] Gigi you
would think that I would bring up some
other [__] maybe some other let's just
backtrack with all the crazy [__] that's
happened this week alright burn
made off just got a hundred and fifty
[__] years in jail for being the
piece of [__] that he evidently is
because the guy got convicted for you
know that whole Ponzi scheme I think
that's great
I totally backed that the fact that they
gave him the maximum amount I was
already getting pissed when his lawyer
was like well he's this age now so he's
probably only going to live another 13
years so we want would like if you just
gave him 12 years well why should he get
out at all he's going to live another 13
years well let's give him 14 to make
sure he [__] dies in prison you know
I'll tell you out all the [__] things
that you can do short of like physically
assaulting somebody is you know if you
steal old people's money okay and they
work their asses off their whole life
you know especially some of these rich
old people who you know worked really
hard taking advantage of sweatshop labor
and you come in there and you know I'm
just [__] around but seriously you
know what I mean like and then they end
up having to eat dog food you took their
whole life's work away man I can't
imagine that I mean god bless those old
people for not coming down there and
just literally killing the guy I would
actually contemplate that you know what
kind of jail do you think that they
would send to you send you to if you
like an 85 year old guy who would work
this whole life you get 85 that means
you probably fought in at least one war
so you're a veteran she already got to
be like right there everybody's like
well [__] that that guy used to be a
Marine
you know fought for our freedoms he did
the right thing his whole life then he
got burned by this [__] feathered
mullet jackass and then he shot him in
the head he actually saved us some
[__] some taxpayer money I don't know
what kind of jail would they send you to
they couldn't send you to Leavenworth
it's not like your [__] hot dogs like
Michael Vick right so anyways that guy
got 150 years I think that's that that's
great but I don't understand why those
other bankers who loaned all of our
hard-earned
me out to [__] homeless people you
know who then defaulted on loans and
then not only did they not go to jail
they asked for more [__] money that
they already print and print and then
they charged us the interest on it is
anybody did anybody out there major in
economics can anybody out there explain
to me how how we keep printing money
with no gold behind it and ketchup isn't
like 72 dollars a bottle can anybody out
there can anybody explain that to me you
know and if you listen to this podcast
you know that's a major pet peeve of
mine was when somebody comes up to me
and they tell me that whatever I'm
talking about they majored in it in
college as if that's some sort of
[__] what is the expression thorn in
your crown that's not it jewel in your
side I don't know what the [__] it is
you know what I mean it's like dude you
you I hate people who go to college in
major and [__] and then they think that
that automatically that makes them a
[__] expert on the subject
it's like douchebag you went there and
you read the books that they gave you
okay
the [__] school is aligned with this
certain like viewpoint and then you read
50 [__] books with the same goddamn
viewpoint all right
they're [__] viewpoint which is
encouraging you to go out and pay for a
[__] education that's not even worth
what they're charging you for you to
come out of school be 80 100 grand in
debt somewhere along the line the banks
give you a [__] credit card with like
a three thousand dollar limit only even
though you're only making 300 bucks a
week at Hot Topic or whatever the [__]
you're doing so they get you buried in
that debt and then you're supposed to
knock up some broad by 26 28 have a kid
and then go buy a [__] house he had
done your on the wheel to you in 90
you're [__] done alright so I don't
know what I'm talking about but I'm just
you know what I'm sick of I just don't
like when I make a point somebody
challenges it that's what it is
especially with the college education
but anyways I don't understand why those
guys aren't [__] jail so anyways
let's let's back up more Michael Jackson
I had no idea how big that guy was I
forgot I don't Fenny
other the rest you were like this but I
literally I forgot how famous that guy
was why I should say more like how
talented he was because the last really
to be honest with you from about 91 92
the last 17 18 years was so not even
about his music or his talent it was all
about his plastic surgery those trials
he went through the plastic surgery and
installed a weird stuff and then another
thing about him was I really felt that
he was kind of like a comedian who
stopped writing a brilliant comedian you
know he just kept wearing those penny
loafers and he kept doing that kicking
his leg up you know he does that little
knee thing and then a little mime step
to the side he throws his [__] hand
up into the air sort of the John
Travolta like I'm going to disco dance
but wait a second I'm stopping you know
but anyway so the guy dies and then they
started showing all his videos on MTV if
he can [__] believe it they actually
showed videos on MTV and I came in from
shooting the movie had like 5:00 in the
morning and I sat there and I watched
his videos for like a [__] hour and I
remembered once again how I would a
giant that guy was I don't if you guys
are old like me but for some of you
youngsters out there when that thriller
video came out I can't even agree it was
ridiculous I just wish you could just
watch all the videos that that like had
taken place before that video have you
ever seen that journey one that awful
journey video where I mean I'm not
really into the music of journey but
those were all top-notch [__]
musicians alright what's-his-face there
their lead singer their unbelievable
voice even I just didn't like and their
drummer Steve Smith is like he continued
to head he's like one of the greatest
drummers in the world right now
considered that but for some reason when
they made the video you have all these
top-notch [__] musicians for some
reason they decided that they should
have
rather than have one of the greatest
drummers in the world drum they that he
should air drum and that all the
guitarists should air guitar and then
the worst thing ever they had the
keyboardist air keyboard and then they
were all [__] just hunched in
together like sort of just stomping
their foot it was [__] embarrassing
then so anyway so thriller came out and
basically what MTV would do was they
actually had a debut of the video that's
how [__] huge it was I remember they
used to do debuts but it was just
everybody [__] watched it and it
wasn't just like they debuted and then
it was in the rotation they like showed
it at like whatever like 3 o'clock in
the afternoon right as the kids came
home from school and then they were like
we will be showing it again at 6:00 and
then you go live your little [__] you
know I'm 12 year old life and then you
come back as with [__] 558 you'd sit
there with your John the floor you'd
watch it again and then they'd be like
we're going to show it again at 9:00 and
then once you know right before you went
you'd watch it again and then the next
day everybody go to school do they still
have four times I saw it five times no
where you'd have to stay up to three the
[__] moon like these stupid arguments
and they did that full atom for like a
[__] week it was unreal I actually
watched it I what that's the first time
I'd actually showed the full-length one
I don't think I've seen the full-length
version of that since the 80s and I
don't know it was [__] amazing and
then it's also sad because you're
looking at the guy yeah that's what I
was doing I look at the old videos I'm
like he was a good-looking guy the [__]
did he do or like as you're watching him
gradually you know have operations Jesus
right there we should have stopped right
there right right there stop freeze one
two three red light but he just kept
[__] going and I don't know one other
thing that pissed me off was I was
reading in the post there was a guy
writing for the post saying how he
actually was at the second child
molestation trial and was saying how
ridiculous it was and how he couldn't
even believe it went to trial that the
charges were such [__]
I just remember thinking going where the
[__] was that story in the post during
that time because I was reading a post
because I liked the sports page and all
they did was just talk about what if you
know they had him convicted in the paper
so my mind he was [__] convicted I
hate when papers do that like they go
all the way to the left and then when
they realize you know that they can't go
to the left anymore then they present
the [__] right you know I don't know
what the [__] I'm saying that but all I
know is I actually started believing
that he was just a really gullible
jackass it was kind of wide open to that
stuff but you know then this is out this
how I'm gonna leave it because the guy
was acquitted twice I'm gonna I'm gonna
believe that he was innocent but this is
the deal I would believe that the guy
was innocent but if I had a kid I
wouldn't leave him alone with them for
like three seconds how about that
you know I mean that's that's not Mike I
hear you I totally believe you
yeah those charges we're [__] up we're
going to go now
and yeah we're going to slowly back
towards the car and as I listened for
the choo-choo train as it goes around
your house to make sure that I don't get
run over by it I know I don't want a
glass of wine thank you thank you very
much
Farrah Fawcett died this is a really sad
week Farrah Fawcett I believe that was
my first no it wasn't you know what Kate
Jackson was my first fantasy famous
girlfriend and that's when she was on
the rookies you guys remember the
rookies Ben nnnnnn banana in it Ben nnnn
it did it did it did it did it did it
did it did it did it did it did remember
that [__] were there those great
seventies [__] TV shows and all right
theme songs like that anymore right
number SWOT bomb but not bobbing apple
bobbing up a banana Stiller delay delay
delay delay van Tibet day but Dilys back
where they had musicians there'd be a
whole [__] Orchestra people used to
make goddamn livings right
TV themes but anyways Kate Jackson she
was like the original Demi Moore however
you say that [__] Cougars name huh
with her [__] lead-pipe titties yeah
she played she was it was the hope she
had the sexy voice absolutely beautiful
eyes beautiful hair the whole [__]
thing she was so [__] hot and she was
dressed like a nurse and there was no
[__] internet there was no porn there
was no I had nothing I was a man without
a [__] country back then so and I
would just sit there [__] Mesmer it
was it was the perfect show and she's
married to the cop the cops character's
name I still remember was Mike Danko
all right that's like a classic 70s
macho I'm [__] hitting it right named
Mike Danko I'm Mike Danko [__]
that's how he should have said it
there's no they should have beeped out
[__] every week when somebody
said his name you know and I used to
watch that show going uncle and that's
what I'm going to do in life I'm gonna
be a cop I'm changing my name to Mike
Danko and I'm marrying some hot-ass
[__] nurse and I'm banging her in
that [__] nurse outfit I don't even
think [__] like that I was like so
innocent I'd even have thoughts like
that I was literally like in love
remember that when you actually had that
in its before yeah you ever met some
girl who just [__] up your whole view
of women and you actually viewed them as
if they were like these angels because
they were so gorgeous you know before
you realize that three out of four weeks
a month they're going to be absolute
[__] maniacs but I digress so yeah so
Farrah Fawcett dies talked about you
know out of all the [__] days to die
you die on a day when a guy do Michael
Jackson is so famous if you guys seen
that thing an entire prison yard in the
Philippines work nine hours to reenact
the Thriller dance and they did it and
they put it up on YouTube these are
prisoners in the [__] Philippines not
the risk of pissing off all you white
trash ice road truckers out there [__]
Elvis Presley Elvis Presley was
he just wasn't anywhere near that he was
he was huge as a bunch of people right
now now wait a minute that's the [__]
king man you don't say that [__] Elvis
Presley was the [__] King you
understand that buddy Michael Jackson
was the King of Pop do you understand
that that means his his kingdom is
clarified he's the king of everything no
he's the king of [__] pop Ellis
President was a [__] King period
which means Michael Jackson was his
[__] subject I get that and also
Elvis Presley didn't have the advantage
of the worldwide web you know what I
mean where you can have as little talent
as the Chocolate Rain guy and you can go
national
so I can only imagine if you know Ed
Sullivan could have put that [__] you
know I don't what the hell I'm talking
about whatever I defend Elvis a little
bit I you know I used to make fun Elvis
and then I went to his house one time
when I was on the road and I went in
there thinking I was going to get a bit
and thinking it was going to be funny
and you know what it was just sad I just
saw a guy who was basically the original
behind the music guy and who was like
even in death we're all why I felt like
I was just like I'm just intruding on
this guy's house and then you walk out
back and in his grave and everybody's
taking pictures next to his grave it's
just like you know that house should be
haunted
like Elvis should literally be haunting
that house and scaring the [__] out of
those [__] people but God knows they
still wouldn't even get it they would
still thinking you know he's singing
he's singing from the grave it's a
little more vulgar than I remember you
know I mean I guess he didn't write his
own lyrics hell he probably [__]
stole them if you believe what some of
them people of color are saying about
his music all right what are we doing
here let's get on with the oh wait a
minute now we have to go back before
that who else [__] died that was some
ed mcmahon died Ed McMahon Edie McMahon
died and I hated after [__] you know
Michael you know Ed McMahon dies then
Farrah Fawcett
and Michael Jackson dies and then
there's always that douchebag who has to
be like [__] sheesh bad things come in
threes
you know bad things come in threes
really what about David David Carradine
you know what about him
he died that makes for stupid some old
lady died of heatstroke I saw that on
the news that's five well was it all in
the same week well you know what I got
two words for you Billy Mays not Billy
Mays and I [__] died too so there you
go that's for famous [__] and
one goddamn week you know what somebody
told me something somebody wrote me a
hilarious [__] email was saying like
how the [__] think they couldn't believe
that they didn't see Billy Mays dying
they couldn't see his death come and
when he clearly looks like he ate four
pounds of bacon every goddamn morning he
really did you ever do I hate when
people do that like you always predict
some [__] after it happens but I gotta
admit once Billy Mays died you were kind
of like what he really did have that
heart attack face didn't he he just had
that that Bluto beard and he was always
screaming and not only that he was
around all that cleaner how many takes
do you think they did is he was sitting
there spraying that oxy wash [__]
whatever the hell it was called that oxy
oxy cleaned you guys ever get that [__]
did you did you feel that a major
White's a whole lot whiter I don't think
it did that's why I think Billy Mays dad
I think was from all that lying he just
couldn't do it anymore screaming about
[__] alarm clocks I can scratch your
back or whatever the hell he had I don't
know so whatever there you go what a
[__] month huh David Carradine god
bless him
and I really think it's bad that people
actually give him [__] I have no problem
with with the fact that he liked to put
on fishnets and hang himself you know I
hope that I'm that much of a freak at 72
[__] years old you know I just I just
I got really like I got inspired by the
fact that he was doing that that at that
age you know what I mean you just
picture your 72 you know you just
[__] hobbling around
hereõs you
I'll tell you that paperboy et3 with a
paper too far away from the door that's
what that's what I picture 72 is you
know you all excited you got that you
can't go up the stairs anymore you got
to sit in that electronic [__] thing
that brings you all the way up the
stairs you know remember that [__] I was
talking about a long time ago where you
have that you have the elevated toilet
seat because anybody can use gravity and
get their [__] old ass down on a
toilet seat but it still takes the quad
strength to get the [__] back up off of
it but you can't afford somebody to help
you up off the toilet seat so you have
to have an elevated toilet seat so you
basically for the rest of your [__]
life you take a [__] [__] standing
there like a third basement you know at
the ready position that's how you take a
[__] you know hands on your knees
standing there like [__] Brooks
Robinson waiting to squeeze one out
little Metamucil wouldn't hurt either
then you got David Carradine see I'm
telling you guys that that's why each
stretching is so [__] unbelievable if
you want to sit that's the biggest thing
you can do other than eating well I
think to try and still feel young
because if you don't stretch your
hamstrings and everything up you don't
stretch it out you get I guess atrophied
I don't know what the [__] that means
all I know is I noticed you know I
haven't been that good about it and I've
been running with my dog and I was like
holy [__] I am rapidly approaching the
age where I can't run anymore you know I
mean that happens anyways at some point
you're not going to be able to run but
if you stop stretching that is the
quickest I think that is the quickest
way and I'm saying that having
absolutely no degree in nutrition
physical therapy or anything whatsoever
so you can take that to the [__] bank
alright let's get into the podcast stuff
here that you guys send it um here's one
for you last week I was talking about
grenades I don't know why I can't
remember why but I somehow as I
presented the question what would happen
if I
you know oh I remember because we were
talking about that that guy sent in that
email about that psycho who lived across
the street who was in the army and he
used to sneak [__] home and try and sell
it the guy was in a bar trying to sell a
[__] grenade and be honest you'd buy
it wouldn't you get three Budweiser's in
you're going through a breakup or maybe
you're just young and you have hope and
you just got that one [__] that that
industrial area that they're just
developing in your town and you're like
alright this is the deal we'll pull the
pin we'll throw it and then we'll
[__] rock it course you're going to
do that so anyway so I presented like I
was wondering like what what the level
of explosion the concussive force
whatever the [__] it is of a grenade
like I had threw a grenade on the other
side of my bed and I dove on the other
side of my bed
blocked up my ears and it exploded okay
and I'm talking about one of those beds
those beds where you know you can't
steal it because they got like the
[__] the wood frame underneath it
would I be able to survive so somebody
from the the Marines told me he said
pill a hand grenade in your hotel room
would definitely [__] your day up with a
15 millimeter kill radius inside of an
an enclosed space your head and [__]
would be indistinguishable
indistinguishable from one another I
hope that answers your question yeah I
would say you were pretty specific there
so anyways for you who suck at math a
meter is a little more than a yard and I
only remember that from that commercial
back in the 70s when they were trying to
teach us the metric system which bombed
miserably so 15 times 3 would be 45 feet
and that is a radius of 45 feet Jesus
Christ so then I wrote the guy back
because I really found that interesting
and I guess because it's enclosed that
the ceiling kind of keeps the blast in
and the walls and all that I guess if
you're outside you have a better chance
I don't know I'd have to talk more about
this but this immediately has opened up
a new podcast thing for anyone who's in
the military
I want to learn about these [__]
weapons and what they can do to you and
I'm going to tell you right now anybody
with a [__] gun there's nothing they
like better than telling you what the
[__] gun would do to you have you
ever noticed that any time somebody gets
a gun what do they say I I you know I
just got it to go hunting right and then
you'd be like well what's you know
what's what's that gun like in the guys
do from here if I shot you right from
here and I shot your whole [__]
shoulder would come off your spinal cord
would be dangling they always do that
[__] so you know what's the point I
haven't a weapon if you don't know what
it would do to a human being that's what
I say huh anybody else anybody else a
Braveheart fan um all right you know I
actually sat down a what's in the whole
history of the machine gun it was really
fascinating like this guy actually
developed the machine gun because he
thought it was going to save lives when
he was in the Civil War he was Gatlin
was a guy like the Gatlin gun he was
sitting there talking about how he just
saw the unbelievable level of carnage in
the Civil War and you gotta remember
that's American shooting Americans so
even if you're winning you know it's
it's just a brutal thing and he was
saying that if he got a machine gun if
it could do the work of 15 [__]
people or 20 people then that would be
19 less people who'd be out in the
battlefield who could possibly lose
their lives of course he didn't do the
math of well if they get one too then
you need to have another guy with a
machine gun and then it just keeps
[__] escalating but I did find it
interesting or maybe that was just the
[__] that he said because he felt
bad that he was making money off of
creating a weapon that could just
literally mow down people anyway so
here's the second part of the the
grenade thing I figured what did I ask
him
oh I remember then this whole I emailed
that guy back and I said okay so what if
I had a suite a hotel suite and I throw
it out into the living room area I
closed the door in the bedroom and I'd
go behind the bed so then he proceeded
to take a lot of time out of his day
which I appreciate he wrote me a nice
long email so this ladies and gentlemen
is the answer to what if you had
the sweet and you little you [__]
pulled the pin on a grenade closed your
bedroom door and go behind the bed see I
asked the questions that America wants
to know all right here we go this guy
said I did five years in the Marines he
said I got on the post 9/11 redneck
bandwagon but by the time I got to Iraq
in 2006 we stopped using hand grenades
indoors normally normally we would just
love a few of those [__] in a room
and not have to worry about the [__]
on the other side he goes I know that's
cold-blooded but hey he can have his 73
virgins of an unspecified gender you
know what that's a funny ass [__]
loophole they really just say you get 73
virgins they don't say that they are
women do they that's [__] that's a great
analogy anyways he said and we replaced
them with flash grenades basically we
didn't want to kill innocent people and
wind up on the cover of Time magazine as
the winner of [__] of the year then
we after we throw in the flash flash I
just literally lost my place to the
flash grenades then we would charge into
the room shooting like I was in the
goddamn Matrix but anyways I have seen
hand grenades go off and there are a two
wait there are two ways a standard
fragmentation grenade can kill you
one the blast itself which generally
projects in a 15 foot radius is anybody
out there can anybody explain to me the
blast itself how that kills you because
if you're not getting hit by shrapnel
just the blast is that basically like
the most psychotic invisible front kick
is that what an explosion is and in that
that the air the force of the blast just
hits you so hard it's like getting hit
by like an invisible truck is that what
it is to be honest with you I've always
kind of thought about that but I never
really sat down and tried to figure it
out and that's basically what I was able
to to come up with having not researched
anyways but anyways the guy says the
concussion
from the blasts turns your insides into
jello if you're within a 5 meter bubble
so is that what happens you know what I
mean so literally it's like getting hit
by this invisible [__] what it would
it Bruce Lee have the one-inch punch
it's like getting hit by a foot like
that times [__] 200 I don't know why
don't I read the rest of us maybe we'll
find out the second way you can die a
horrific death is from a frag grenade is
the fragmentation from the shell of the
grenade and the fragmentation of all the
other [__] like wood and pieces of other
people that the blast turns into
shrapnel wow Jesus Christ you know what
I mean as much as you watch the
beginning a Saving Private Ryan like you
still really can't ever capture how
[__] horrific that must be the amount
of damage of frag will do to you in the
next room depends on the wall in your
suite what it's made out of if the walls
are made out of concrete with rebar and
[__] inside you'll more than likely just
[__] your pants that's amazing so if
there isn't like rebar in there which
I'm imagining is those little steel
things
it could still [__] kill you if the
wall is thin and some of the
fragmentation make may go through the
wall and hit you but you'll be safe from
the blast itself and probably will
probably live I'll just be screaming on
the floor like that guy in platoon is
Barnes crawls over and digs the [__] out
with a knife
good lord god bless you guys man I
really do not have a difficult life here
alright more most doors on hotel rooms
are pretty solid so I think they could
take a direct hit and not damage
anything on the other side also it
depends on the type of grenade American
hand grenades are the largest and the
deadliest USA USA that's right [__]
America baby the Russian grenades are a
little bit smaller I like this I like
the whole the whole phallic thing going
on here with less fragmentation but I
would I still wouldn't want to be in the
same [__] zip code when one goes off
and then the second question I asked him
was hearing loss is a big thing for me
because
I play drums without earplugs for a
while and I also went and saw a CD seen
a bunch of other heavy metal bands and
every other time I wore earplugs and I
have tinnitus in my right ear which is a
you know sometimes it can be a buzzing
sound or it can be just a ringing sound
and it never goes away and it's driven
people to suicide if it's loud enough
mine fortunately isn't it's just like
like right now I can barely hear it like
if I actually just stop talking if I
stop talking like late at night I can
hear it when there's nothing going on if
there's no background noise I just sort
of hear like just really low just sorta
II in my ear I know a lot of you just
was like holy [__] that must be crazy
but yeah actually that's my phone by the
way if you went in with the other
soundest that's not the sound in my ear
that's it letting me know that I have
some [__] new Texas but anyways yeah
I was always wondering like how these
guys are in war and then shooting these
[__] machine guns and all this type
of stuff like how do you not lose your
hearing and he said to answer your
second question he said I have a
condition called tinnitus which I
basically explained all I have them
explaining - so which is a permanent
permanent ringing in my ears and my left
ear is pretty [__] up as well some
dude opened up with a machine gun right
next to my head and I didn't have an ear
plug in my left ear so I guess you guys
wear ear plugs over there but I would
think sometimes if you get ambushed you
don't have a min and then you just got
to [__] open up anyways I don't
really notice the ringing unless it's
really [__] quiet and since I live in
the middle of a dense urban area it's
never really [__] quiet so it's not
an issue in combat we wear earplugs that
work pretty well
shooting aside small rooms is still
pretty [__] loud though the loudest
thing over there our aircraft and
anything that explodes I'm talking about
the loudest [__] thing you would ever
hear in your life also we normally
communicate non-verbally through hand
signals and just knowing where you
should be in a certain situation all
he's addressing the fact that you know
you always watch those cop movies and in
a sort of whisper after they shot a
couple of rounds you know and I've shot
a gun without [__]
earplugs that's another dumb thing I did
with my hearing and I couldn't hear
think so there's no [__] way I could
then whisper to somebody next to me
going hey you go around back and I'll
try to keep it busy here because I gotta
be going like hey I can't [__] hear
you so anyways he said they use hand
signals anyways besides shouting within
earshot of the enemy is [__] since
they counter-attack and the element of
surprise is lost this email is probably
longer than that ladies oh that lady's
who made fun of your suit on Conan now
dude I totally appreciate that man if
there's anybody else out there that like
really that's like some time life books
kind of stuff you know when they talk
about what it's really like so if
anybody else if I have anybody who's
overseas god knows you get the internet
over there if you're over there in Iraq
or if you're over there in Afghanistan
and I'm trying to think of a question or
any of the listeners have any questions
and stuff over there I got one for you
you know you sit there and you train and
you go through bootcamp and you do all
that stuff you know and you get yourself
ready for battle and then you're going
over there you know I know my biggest
fear would have been like what am I
going to be that guy who freezes up and
is crying in the fetal position spooning
his weapon in a foxhole that someone's
screaming at me private bar for Christ's
sake get your [__] together you best
unfuck yourself Pyle I mean what happens
is does it just naturally click in
because I would think even in my first
battle even if I didn't [__] out I
would still be a spaz it's [__] empty
an entire clip I remember talking to
cops about this [__] we had this cop on
my radio show uninformed and by the way
I have a new episode coming out we taped
one yesterday that will be out on July
3rd you can listen to that on XM 202 and
anyways this cop was saying how a lot he
worked with guys the first time they
pulled their weapon this is this is an
old-school guy so they still had like
the six shooter and was saying they
pulled that gun out of the holster and
by the time they brought it up level
with the suspect they were
literally out of bullets because they
would be pulling it out and like
shooting literally to the ground in
front of them they've had guys shoot
themselves in the foot just I just can't
imagine the [__] adrenaline that is
going through your body when something
like that is happening so you know if
it's not too painful obviously I'm not
trying to have a big therapy session
here this is supposed to be a comedy
[__] so if you got some funny stories
or anything like that uh listen me you
got any funny stories about war and
engaging the enemy I don't know anything
that you would think would be [__]
interesting because I don't think I can
I can answer any more questions about
comedy I pretty much answered them all
but I don't know kind of speaking for
the group here but I find that stuff
really interesting because my only frame
of reference is when I watch movies and
you see these guys you know they throw
you never see that in the movie like
there's a grenade lands near the guy so
then somebody dies on top of it to save
his buddy's life now from I always
thought that you could do that but
having just read that last one evidently
if I did that then just you know all the
200 whatever bones in my body would just
turn into shrapnel and you know I don't
know people would die around me but they
were definitely rolling around the
ground trying to get my femur out of the
side of their [__] neck so we all
learned something alright let's get on
with the the podcast questions and you
know it's just not the question is
obviously posed to all veterans cops
anybody rednecks
if you God knows you probably threw a
grenade at a duck and it's bill came
back and hit you in your foot now you
got a limp any any of those [__]
stories I would I would love to hear all
right podcast questions of the week this
is a really interesting one this guy
says bill I come from a family where
more than half of the women have gotten
pregnant in their teens and almost all
the men have ended up in jail in jail at
various points in their lives so I've
seen firsthand how having a kid when
you're not ready and going to prison at
an early age can really [__] up your
life and because I'm trying not to
because I'm trying to end the tradition
of poverty and dysfunction in my family
I am very hesitant towards trying to
hook up with random women and can be
considered a bit of a nerd also due to
the fact that I don't have like two or
three baby mothers and I'm never
bringing girls around the family you
guessed it I've now been accused of
being gay I guess by his his his family
members Wow okay
thought I came from a dysfunctional
family
alright I hope you see my dilemma here
if I go out of my way to prove I'm not
gay then I'm acting acting like the
classic homophobe I'm not cool with that
I'm also giving them power by trying to
conform to their perception of what a
quote-unquote real man is but if I
ignore it they continue to talk [__] it
would be different if if it were a
collection of douche bag jocks saying
things like this but it's not this is my
[__] family the people who are
supposed to love me unconditionally and
yes as sad as it may seem my family
members are that stupid and ignorant
they think being gay is something that
warns being made fun of although I can I
can really see the humor in this it
really does hurt a little doing the
right thing by staying in school and
trying to make something out of my life
while staying out of trouble has gotten
me where I'm accused of being gay I'm so
disgusted with my family that I'm
seriously considering cutting each
member out of my family life even my own
mother parenthesis my father's dead your
thoughts I think you're doing an amazing
thing to be honest with you I think one
of the hardest things to do is to grow
up in a [__] up environment and to be
in the environment and be surrounded by
it totally immersed in it yet still have
the ability to pull yourself out of it
and analyze it and look at how other
people are living and if they're living
in a smarter way or a way that appeals
to you more to actually try to go and
try to go in that direction without
doing what most normal people what most
people do in that situation is they just
look at other people if they're living a
smarter life they just dismiss them as
[__]
you know I want to go to college like
these are a bunch of figs you know yeah
that's that's a lesson I learned late in
life that you really have to watch out
who you're who you surround yourself
with because you basically end up for
the most part you end up doing what they
do you just get sucked into their vortex
so I think that's the right word
whatever the [__] is you get sucked into
that they're little they're world and so
if you're hanging out with people who
are doing dumb [__] [__] up their
lives the chances are you [__] up
your life is going to be huge and dude
you don't want two or three babies with
with two or three different women you
know that everybody knows that and even
those [__] retards who are doing it
they know that and you know what it
really is I really think this is a
classic example of misery loves company
and they when they're laying in bed at
night they know that they [__] their
lives up and you know what when people
[__] their lives up you know what you do
you lay in bed and you think about the
first day that day when you [__] your
life up and you wish you could just go
back to it and make a left instead of
making a right that's what the [__]
they're doing and the harsh reality is
you can't go back in time and which
leaves you with one of two things you
can even either man up and admit that
you're the reason and you're responsible
for you know for the fact that your life
is [__] up and you try to make the
best of it and try to actually help
other people not make the same mistakes
you have that's the most noble thing
that you can do or you can take the easy
way out like most people and is try to
[__] do that misery loves company and
drag everybody down with you that's all
they're trying to do they're trying to
drag you down to the bottom of the
swimming pool so you can drown in their
[__] misery too so you're doing the
right thing and if you have to I don't
know if you got to like totally cut them
out because it is your family that is
your mom and at some point you know you
know they're not going to be around
forever so it's never good to not go for
long periods without communicating with
your family but you just kind of got to
give yourself
halftime speech or a pregame speech
before you talk to them to make sure
that uh you know you basically stay on
point and yeah dude that those are my
thoughts you're totally doing the right
thing and I think energy a really strong
person that you were able to see how
[__] up your family was that's a hard
thing to do you know and try and correct
it you know so it'll be great so then
you'll end up with the right woman you
end up having great kids and then you'll
break the you'll break that circle but
the problem that's dead you'll then run
into is then when you have kids is then
they're going to want their fucked-up
kids to hang out with your enlightened
kids and that'll be the hard thing
because they are your cousins in
whatever I don't know it's a [__]
mess but dude you're on the right track
so what do I think you should keep doing
what you're doing and try to find some
middle ground where you keep them at an
arm's length but you don't totally sever
ties and when they and when they give
you [__] you know about being gay just
give them [__] right back oh really
really really I'm gay what because I
don't have some [__] psycho coming in
here trying to burn down my [__]
clothes because I knocked up another
[__] broad now don't do that don't go
for that's what I would do I go for the
jugular like dude your life sucks okay
what's it like earning four hundred
dollars a week and giving it and
dividing up three hundred and eighty of
it and [__] giving it to three
different women and then it going down
to the [__] hot dog truck and buying
you dinner you dumb [__] you know put a
shirt on and get your [__] together I
don't know I would just say mean [__]
don't listen to me that's the first part
of my advice was good but yeah try to
find I don't know you know what talk to
somebody else for the second half all
right I'm not Deepak Chopra but I got I
think the first half of the advice I
gave you was good all right okay so
that's it you're doing the right thing
there you go something positive all
right next question hey Bill since
you're pretty big sports fan I was
wondering what we our opinion over your
opinion of soccer
I'm not much of a fan I basically only
watched some of the World Cup but today
at the restaurant I was watching Brazil
vs. USA game and a few of my Brazilian
co-workers we're watching the game and
for the first half for the first half I
had a blast watching the game because
basically I got to play out the
stereotypical over-the-top clueless
American they were just dying inside
when the US scored the first two goals
and I got to [__] with them I was
yelling [__] like throw the flag I'll
tell you what Brazil needs to do they
should call a timeout and regroup and
then my co-workers were taking me
serious furiously telling me that there
are no timeouts in soccer oh that's
great dude they should call a [__]
timeout I'll tell you there's nothing
more fun than playing up the ignorant
America you know that's the greatest
thing you can do when you go to Europe
and they start giving you [__] that you
don't know anything about their country
embrace it and just be like yeah dude I
got to be honest nobody talks about your
country in my country we have you know
who the [__] you guys are what do I
can't believe you're not all walking
around on wooden shoes over here you
guys have cars you know just [__]
play it up all right anyways he said my
co-workers were taking me seriously
furiously telling me their own time outs
and he said once the u.s. scored the
second goal
I yield what are the odds I'd say about
a Brazilian 2-1 did I actually wish I
was there to see this you really sound
obnoxious that must have been great then
he goes he goes but then in the long run
they ended up giving me [__] because as
I was watching the game I was thinking
why why not have Brazil take all this is
a big conspiracy theory he goes but as I
was watching the game I thought it's
something that I'm amazed at the f o fi
FA didn't arrange us to make it happen I
was thinking why not have Brazil take a
dive against the US but you know make it
look good and then the next year when
the World Cup came around the interest
in the US would be through the roof you
know let the US beat Brazil and then you
you spend
out a bunch of t-shirts you split them
50/50 with the Brazilian you know the
whole we kicked Brazilians ass
Brazil has been in 15 years when
everyone has forgot about the game
that's when you make the movie what do
you think about the idea bill well I
think I read it a little bit better
would have made more sense you think it
would have worked um yeah I think we
beat Brazil in us the US team started
building up you know something actually
I don't think it would have worked
because those people down there take
soccer way too seriously
Brazil takes it really seriously but
they're not like like Colombia or was it
Colombia like was it the venezuelan team
somebody accidentally put the ball in
their own net and the guy went home and
he got [__] machine-gunned
like the [__] st. Valentine's Day
Massacre you know so no I don't think it
would work I think would work in America
because we don't give a [__] about
soccer alright I think that's the end of
the questions that I have anything else
here I'm a little disorganized uh all
right how about this about a movie
review and then I'm going to end this
podcast oh man I have to end it now this
is too [__] long I'll read one really
quickly The Punisher movie review based
on the Marvel comic character Thomas
Jane who was in the mist the dream
catcher and the Thin Red Line stars is
Frank Castle who is a former Green Beret
that becomes an FBI agent Castle has one
last bus to make that involves stolen
weapons and during the bus the son of a
mob boss Howard Saint played by John
Travolta is killed Saint wants vengeance
on who got his son killed and finds out
the castle is one of the one who caused
st. son's death not to spoil anything
but [__] happens and castle gets in his
Camaro to [__] ship some [__] up I give
it 2 out of 4 stars it's a movie that
tries to be realistic which is great
compared to the over-the-top cliche
action sequences in the sequel it's
definitely worth the rent or purchasing
as how it's five dollars on DVD and ten
dollars on blu-ray at Best Buy or
Walmart and there are two versions the
three theatrical and the extended
edition so this guy gives it two out of
four stars basically saying the Punisher
is a good rental
all right and that's the podcast for
this week I hope you guys enjoyed it
there's going to be one more podcast out
here in New York City and then I will
finally be back out in Los Angeles so oh
maybe actually I'll be in San Francisco
yeah because July 13th is a Monday and I
will be doing two shows at the punchline
in San Francisco and I've yet to put
those up on my site so I have to do that
and the next big date I have is I'm
going to be doing the Comedy Works in
Denver Colorado I believe the dates of
the 23rd to 24th and the 25th so please
come out and check that out and if
you're a fan of my radio show with the
uninformed show with Joe DeRosa we have
a new episode coming out this Saturday
July 4th I think I said the 3rd early
earlier but July 4th listen to it from
9:00 to midnight on XM 202 I will be
sending out an email blast just to give
you guys a heads up when I get the exact
time all right so that's it for the
podcast you guys all have a great week
and don't take any [__]
okay come on
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
Oh
[Music]
when you
Oh